The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
Welcome to our final lecture
in part three of calculus.
And I suppose it would be nice
to have an appropriate story
to tell.
And the only story
I can think of
is, on the transatlantic
flight, the stewardess coming in
to the passenger's cabin
midway over the Atlantic Ocean
and saying to the
passengers, well,
I have some good news and
some bad news for you.
The bad news is that
we're almost out of gas.
And the good news is that
we're making wonderful time.
And the reason I thought
of this particular story
is that, in a sense, we
are not almost out of gas,
but in terms of this being a
fundamentals type of course
in which we're trying to
give the ingredients of what
goes into all advanced
mathematics courses,
we have sort of come
to the end of the road.
We have finished the so-called
ABC's of mathematics.
As far as making wonderful
time is concerned,
I would say we've done
deliberately just the opposite,
that we have essentially taken
one or two central themes
and tried to unify all
of elementary calculus
in terms of these
central themes.
And when you do
something like this,
it's very difficult to come
to the end of a course.
You sort of don't
know where to stop.
So you go back to a
little trick that you
learned in about the third grade
when you wrote compositions
where you learned that
you could write anything
that you wanted as long
as the last line was,
we all had a very nice time.
So we now must look
for a line along
those particular thoughts.
And if we recall that we
began as our major theme
in this course the idea
of mathematical structure,
the idea of what new math really
meant, not new meaning brand
new, but new meaning the
opposite of passe, new meaning
meaningful, I can
think of no nicer way
of ending the course than
by picking as an application
a topic that existed long before
the so-called new math was
born, and which
exists in an even
more enlightened way in the
spirit of the new mathematics.
And the topic that I have
in mind to conclude with--
and it also ties in with
our lecture of last time
on the dot product--
is the subject called
orthogonal functions,
which has as a special
subtopic, Fourier series.
Now the way this comes
about is the following.
And you have to know
nothing about vector spaces
to appreciate what we're going
to do now, that in a sense
we imitate what Fourier
actually did in trying to solve
a particular type of problem.
We suppose that we have an
infinite sequence of, functions
which I'll denote by
the family phi sub
n of x, and a particular
closed interval
from a to b such that each
member of my family phi sub n
of x is integral on the
interval from a to b.
And we'll also assume
that the integral from a
to b of the product of any
two of these functions, two
different members of the
set, that that integral is 0.
In other words, the
interval from a to b
phi sub i of x times
phi sub j of x dx
is 0, provided i
is unequal to j.
So we're assuming this
particular property,
remembering of course
that the product of two
integral functions
is, again, integrable
so that this thing makes sense.
Now traditionally, when
a family of functions
had this particular
property, that family
was set to be orthogonal on
the interval from a to b.
And I will leave
it for a little bit
later to show you how this jibes
with the meaning of orthogonal
as we defined it in terms
of dot products last time.
Let me show you how,
for example, Fourier
decided to use this
type of information.
Suppose we had a
given function f
of x that also happened to
be integrable on the interval
from a to b.
Or written more
succinctly, we assume
that the integral from
a to b f of x dx exists.
Let's also suppose
that f of x happens
to be a linear
combination of the members
of the orthogonal family phi
sub n of x, in other words,
that for the given
orthogonal family, f of x
is summation Cn phi n of x
as n goes from 1 to infinity.
And the question is, under--
or with the knowledge that
this is an orthogonal family,
how can we determine
each coefficient C sub
n if this condition
here is the whole?
Or to make this more
concrete and keep
it as non-symbolic
as possible, let's
suppose I wanted to figure
out here what C sub 3
happened to be.
The trick is this.
I recognize that, from
this basic definition,
if I multiply phi sub 3 of x by
any other member of this family
other than phi sub 3
itself and integrate from a
to b, that term will be 0.
So what I do is I come
back to this relationship.
And I multiply both sides of
this equation by phi sub 3
of x, keeping in mind if
I wanted to find C sub k,
I would have multiplied both
sides by phi sub k of x.
I'm just picking
k equals 3 here.
I multiply both sides
by phi sub 3 of x.
And because phi sub 3 of x is
a constant subscript, meaning
it doesn't depend on the
summation n which only affects
the subscript here, I
can bring phi sub up 3
of x inside the summation sign.
Now the trick is I integrate
both sides of this equality
from a to b.
In other words,
I put an integral
from a to b on both sides
here, augment this with a dx.
And I now know that
this is the case.
My next gimmick, if you
want to call it that--
and if you don't
want to call it that,
you should, because
it is a gimmick,
as we'll explain in the moment--
I simply interchange the order
of summation and integration,
remembering that the
integral of the sum
is the sum of the integrals.
I interchange this order.
And I now have the
summation n goes from 1
to infinity integral from a to
b Cn phi n of x phi 3 of x dx.
And now remembering
that the integral
from a to b, phi sub n of
x times phi sub 3 of x dx,
by definition of orthogonality
is 0 unless n equals 3,
all of these terms drop
out except when n equals 3.
Now what happens here?
When n equals 3, this
term here is C sub 3.
This is phi sub 3 squared x
dx integrated from a to b.
And all the remaining terms are
0, because the integrand is 0.
In other words, the right-hand
side simply becomes--
well, since C3 is a
constant, I can take it
outside the integral sign.
It's C3 integral from a to
b C sub 3 squared of x dx.
And now you see from
this relationship here,
I can solve for C sub 3.
Namely, I simply divide
both sides of this equation
by this number here.
Now what I said by
gimmick is simply this.
When we said that
the integral of a sum
is the sum of the integrals,
that was only for a finite sum.
You may remember in
part one of our course
when we talked about uniform
convergence, one of the things
that we pointed out was
that for infinite sums,
you weren't always guaranteed
that you could interchange
the order of summation
and integration.
Or as I usually put it, you
could always interchange them,
but you may not get
the same answer.
So the first question
that comes up
is, how do I know
that I am allowed
to interchange this order?
By the way, the second
question that comes up is--
and this is a more
subtle question,
but going back to what
we're talking about before--
how do I even know that there is
a linear combination of the phi
sub n's that comes out
to be the given f of x?
You see you notice that
our demonstration here
presupposes that f of x
can be written this way.
You see the two
questions that come up
is, given an f of
x, first of all,
can it be written this way?
And secondly, even
if it can, do we
have the right to interchange
the order of integration
and summation?
By the way, assuming
for the moment
that we can do this
mechanically at least,
notice that what
C3 turns out to be
is the integral from
a to b f of x phi sub
3 of x dx divided by the
integral form a to b phi sub 3
of x squared times dx, and
again, replacing the 3 by a k.
This is how every one
of these coefficients
could have been determined.
And now you see, as
a very, very brief
aside which I will go into much
more detail in the study guide
when we talk about the exercises
and the various discussion
of the exercises, given a
series of functions which
is integrable, a
sequence of functions
integrable on a given
interval from a to b,
one usually defines the dot
product of these two functions
to be the integral from a
to b the product of the two
functions times dx.
You see, remember
last time we showed
that all you needed
to have a dot product
was a rule that showed
you how to combine
two members of your set
to give you a number?
And certainly, this
thing here is a number.
And it also had to have three
or four basic properties.
And as one of the
exercises, we will
show that those properties for
a dot product are obeyed here.
But this is where the word
"orthogonal functions"
come from.
Notice that in terms of this
definition of a dot product,
two vectors are orthogonal
if their dot product is 0.
And now they're saying
that this equals
0 is the same as saying
that this integral is 0.
And that's precisely what the
definition of orthogonal was.
So you see, this
is the connection
between the vector space
interpretation of orthogonal
and the traditional
interpretation of orthogonal.
And as I say, I'll
leave further discussion
of that for the notes.
But the important point is this.
If I mechanically solve
for these coefficients--
in other words, suppose
I'm given f of x.
And I'm given a
family of functions
phi sub n of x which is
orthogonal on the interval
from a to b.
Suppose that without even
knowing whether f of x
can be represented as a linear
combination of the phis,
and that without even knowing
whether I can interchange
these two operations, the order
in which I perform these two
operations, let's suppose
that I mechanically
invent as my coefficients the
C's in this particular way.
In other words,
regardless of whether it
means anything or
not, I can always
multiply f of x by phi sub k
of x, integrate from a to b.
You see, the product of
two integrable functions
is always integrable.
I can always divide that by the
square of the function phi sub
k of x from a to b, keeping
in mind, by the way, that
as long as phi sub 3
is not identically 0
or if it's not 0 other than
on a set of points of measure
0, what have you, notice
that the square of a number
can't be negative.
So if phi sub 3 of x
is different from 0
in enough places,
by squaring it,
I have a positive integrand.
And when I integrate
a positive integrand
I can't get 0 for an answer.
So I don't have a
zero denominator here.
But the point is this.
If I choose the
C's as I did here,
see, with the C's as just
defined, we write that f is x--
and then we put a
little squiggle here.
See, don't know if
we had the right
to assume that this series
here is equal to f of x,
but we write this little
squiggle mark here.
We call the resulting infinite
series capital F of x.
And what we say
is that capital F
of x is the Fourier
representation of little f of x
with respect to the
family phi sub n of x.
You see, we don't say
that these two are equal.
But when we choose these
coefficients the way I just
mentioned, this
is, in any event,
called the Fourier
representation of the function
little f of x.
I see there are many
questions that come up.
And in the form of an overview,
let me just state them.
First of all, how do we
know that capital F of x
is even a convergent series?
After all, this is
an infinite series.
How do we know it
even converges?
Secondly, if it does
converge, how do we know
that it converges to f of x?
The answer is we don't know.
We really don't know.
But there is a rather
remarkable result.
And the result is not
that difficult to prove.
But in the form
of an overview, I
prefer to omit the proof here.
It will be an exercise
in the study guide,
but I think it's
important to see what
the statement of the result is.
And then we can talk about
the ramifications of that.
But the proof would
actually obscure
the beauty of the result.
And the aside, which I leave
as an exercise, is simply this.
Suppose you took a
linear combination
of the first n of the terms
phi 1 of x up to phi n of x.
If you choose the C sub k's
to be the so-called Fourier
coefficients the way
I just mentioned,
what is interesting is this,
that even if the Fourier
representation doesn't
converge to f of x,
it has the property that
it gives you the best
least square approximation.
In other words, if
I were to compute
the difference between f of
x and the sum of the first n
terms in the Fourier
representation
where the C's were chosen
according to the method I just
mentioned to you
before and square
that difference-- you
see, this is why it's
called the mean square idea.
You see, large errors and
small errors, in other words,
a large negative error can
cancel a large positive error
because the algebraic signs
tend to cancel one another.
But by squaring large errors,
all of these become what?
Squares of large magnitudes
are large positive magnitudes.
By squaring, I really
magnify the errors.
The positives can't
cancel the negatives.
And what this says
is that if I use
this linear combination
of the phi sub n's,
that the square
approximation error is less
using these coefficients
than if I had used
any other possible
coefficients, that if I picked
any other coefficients in the
whole world other than the ones
that I found by the method
indicated just a little while
ago, if I summed these
terms, subtracted that
from f of x squared and
integrated the results from a
to b, I would get a number
which was at least as large.
And in most cases in
fact, unless the d sub k's
were chosen to equal
the C sub k's, I
would get a number which
was larger than this.
Now you see what
this thing says?
What this says is that there
can't be any real interval
where this gets
very, very far away
from f of x, because you see,
if it did, if it did get very,
very far away, this would
be a large magnitude.
Squaring it would give me
a positive large magnitude.
Integrating that from a to b
would make this thing still
very, very large.
And why should it stay
smaller than any other linear
combination that I can get?
And I'll emphasize this
more from a concrete point
of view in a few moments.
But for the time being, what the
impact of this beautiful result
is-- and notice, it
doesn't look like much when
you look at it like this.
It just looks like
some abstract remark.
But the beauty of this
remark the impact of it
is that, when you write
the so-called Fourier
representation, as opposed to
power series, which I'll also
mention at the end
of the lecture what
the contrast really is, the
Fourier representation, if it
does converge at all, converges
to the function, what we call
in the large, that
over the whole interval
it starts to fit the
function very nicely.
Now I'll come back
to that in terms
of a more specific
example in a few moments.
Let me point out that, Fourier,
being basically an engineer
and a scientist, worked
with one particular set
of orthogonal functions, a set
of orthogonal functions that
were very, very natural
to anybody working
with wave motion or
things of this type,
as you'll see in a moment.
The special case that
I have in mind is this.
Consider the family
of functions--
well, I can call
this cosine 0x, which
is another way of writing 1.
But I have 1 cosine x, cosine
2x, cosine 3x, cosine 4x,
et cetera, and also
included in this family,
sine x, sine 2x,
sine 3x, et cetera.
I claim that this
family of functions
is orthogonal on the interval
from negative pi to pi.
What I mean by that is what?
That if I take any two different
members of this family,
multiply them together,
integrate from minus pi to pi,
the result will always be 0.
Now the-- I won't go
through this whole thing.
That will also be one of the
exercises in the study guide
will be to verify this.
But let me give you a
head start in doing this.
Let me pick two members of the
cosine, two different numbers
of the cosine family here,
and multiply them together,
and integrate from
minus pi to pi.
In other words, let me
take integral from minus pi
to pi cosine mx cosine nx
dx where m is unequal to n.
Now again, without
belaboring this point,
remember that the formula
for cosine a cosine b
comes from looking at the
formulas for cosine a plus b
cosine of a minus b and
adding these two results.
And the sine a sine
b terms drop out.
To make a long story
short, or somewhat shorter,
cosine mx times cosine
nx is another way
of writing one half
the sum of cosine m
plus nx plus cosine m minus n x.
Now you see, to integrate
this, very simply,
this just gives me what?
A 1/2 here.
This is sine m plus
n x over m plus n.
This is sine m minus x--
m minus n times
x over m minus n.
And those, by the way, the
fact that m is unequal to n,
guarantees me that my
denominator here can't be zero.
And at any rate, noticing
that when I evaluate this
from x equals minus pi to
pi, that these are integral,
meaning whole-number
multiples of pi,
both these terms are zero.
And we've established the
fact that this is zero.
So at least the members of the
cosine family are orthogonal.
One can also show the members of
the sine family are orthogonal.
And one can also show that any
member of the cosine family
taken--
multiplied by any member of
the sine family integrated
from minus pi to
pi also gives zero.
So the point then
is, fair enough,
that this family here
is an orthogonal family
on the interval
from minus pi to pi.
And the beauty of this result--
and let me point out
that in textbooks
on advanced mathematics,
the multitude of pages
I use to prove the
results, but the statements
of the terms that
you prove are not
that difficult to keep track of.
Let me just give one major
result, a result that
is very, very crucial,
and one that I will
emphasize in the study guide.
And that is this.
Suppose that I am given a
particular function little
f of x, which is piecewise
smooth on the interval
from minus pi to pi.
And remember what I mean
by piecewise smooth.
I mean it's a differentiable
function except that it
may have a finite number
of jump discontinuities,
that if I plot the
graph y equals f of x,
I get a smooth curve with
the possible exception
that there may be a few jumps
in it, by few meaning what?
A not-too-great infinite
number, a set of measures
zero type thing.
But we won't belabor
that point right now.
But the idea is this.
Suppose that I have this
piecewise smooth function
little f of x.
And suppose capital
F of x is the Fourier
representation of little f
of x relative to my sines
and cosines.
In other words, capital F of
x is the linear combinations
of the cosine terms
and the sine terms
where the coefficients are
chosen by that little recipe
that I showed you at the
beginning of the lecture,
and which, as I
say, I'll reinforce
as we do the exercises.
At any rate, let's call
this capital F of x.
And in this particular
case, in other words,
what particular case?
If little f of x
is piecewise smooth
and the orthogonal functions
are the sines and cosines
on the interval from
minus pi the pi, then
the Fourier representation
of f of x, capital F of x,
is given by the following.
And this is a
remarkable result. It
says that capital F
of x at any value of x
in the interval
from minus pi to pi
is little f of x plus plus
little f of x minus over 2.
Now, what does f of x plus mean?
That means the limit of f of x
as you approach the given value
of x from the positive side.
And this f is x
minus is the limit
of f of x as you approach
the given value of x
from the negative side.
In fact, to keep this
easier to understand
so I don't use x in two
different ways, what I'm saying
is capital F of x sub 0
is computed as follows.
See what little f of x sub
0 is as x approaches x0
from the left.
See what f of x0 of f of x
approaches as x approaches x0
from the right.
Add these two results
and divide by 2.
I hope that you can see
that what I'm doing here
is taking the average
of these two results.
Half the sum is the average.
Also observe that if f happens
to be continuous at x0,
f of x0 plus is the
same as f of x0 minus.
You see, the only time
that these two things can
be different is if there is
a jump in the function at x0,
because if there is no jump,
as I approach x0 from the left
and approach x0 from the
right, the two values I get
must be the same.
In other words, notice
that at the points where
f is continuous, this is nothing
more than f of x0 itself.
And what this famous
result says is
that, except at the points
at which little f of x
is discontinuous, capital F,
the Fourier representation,
is little f itself,
that the Fourier
representation converges
to the function itself.
And what it does
that's remarkable
is that where there is
a jump in the function,
it equals the
average of the jump.
Well, let me show you that
in terms of an example.
Let me pick a very simple
function to begin with.
Let me define the
function little f
of x to be negative 1 when x is
in the interval from minus pi
to 0.
And let it be, say,
positive 1 when x is
in the interval from 0 to pi.
So graphically, you see how
this thing is going to look.
It goes like this.
By the way, notice that this
is what mathematically we
call an odd function.
F of x is the negative
of f of minus x.
Notice that the
sine terms are odd.
The cosine terms are even.
You see, cosine of x is the
same as cosine of minus x.
But sine of x is
minus sine minus x.
So the sine terms are odd.
The cosine terms are even.
So the first hint or the
first nice simplification
that takes place by
choosing this example
is that because this
is an odd function,
the cosine terms
will all be absent.
And it turns out that if I use
the procedure indicated earlier
in the lecture--
and again that will be
one of the exercises
so that you get the drill
that's necessary here,
again, I only want to
give you the overview--
it turns out that the
Fourier series representation
of this particular
function, capital F of x,
turns out to be 4 over pi
times the summation sine
n x over n for n odd.
And what that means is
it's 4 over pi times
sine x plus sine 3x over 3
plus sine 5x over 5, et cetera.
By the way, these are very
difficult things to draw.
You're not used to
working with these.
I should point out this, that
if there is anything that
works nicely in the laboratory,
it's sine and cosine terms,
because those are things
that you can produce
very nicely on an oscilloscope.
Analytically, these are
very nasty terms to handle.
But electronically,
it's a very nice way
of getting a feeling
for Fourier series.
But I don't have
electronic chalk here,
so I just talk about it and
draw these things for you.
But for example, to
show you what I mean
here, let me just take
the first two terms.
Let me plot the curve y
equals 4 over pi times
the quantity sine x
plus sine 3x over 3.
And if I plot that curve,
which I've done here
in the accentuated
chalk, look at how nicely
that curve starts already to
fit the graph y equals f of x.
You see how it fits over here?
No perfect fit any place, but
notice that, by and large, it
fits the curve very nicely
without too big an error all
the way along here.
It has roughly the right shape.
And notice also it goes
through the origin,
because when x is 0,
capital F of x is 0.
And that's exactly the
average of the jump over here.
So you jump from minus 1 to 1.
So the origin is the
average over here.
By the way, even though I
don't draw very well, what
I have tried to do
here is show what
happens if I tack on just
a couple of more terms.
I've tacked onto this
the term sine 5x over 5
and sine 7x over 7.
And then the graph would
look something like this.
You see how nicely
this starts to fit?
It fits very nicely along here.
But wherever there's a jump,
it jumps to-- it averages
out this way.
By the way, one
other observation--
obviously, the function
is I'm constructing here
is periodic with period 2 pi.
If I replace x by x plus 2 pi,
I don't change the sine any.
And so obviously,
the function which
I'm calling capital F
of x represents more
than this given function.
Rather, it represents the given
function reproduced infinitely
in both directions
with period 2 pi.
But again, I'll leave
that for the exercises.
To summarize what's
happened over here,
you see how nicely
this thing fits?
If I actually took capital F
of x and computed this limit
for each value of x,
what the graph would look
like-- now obviously,
I can't get this
on the oscilloscope, because
no matter how many terms I use,
no matter how large a
number, n is still finite.
But if I actually
took the infinite sum,
the graph that I would
get mathematically
is I would actually get the
straight line x equals--
I'm sorry, y equals
negative from minus pi to 0.
It would be y equals
positive 1 from 0 to pi.
And at 0 itself, the
function would be 0.
You see, it splits the gap.
It splits the jump.
And then of course, the
function would repeat itself
at a regular interval of--
regular period of 2 pi, that
this is what capital F of x
would look like
if you graphed it.
By the way, to give you an
example of an even function,
if we were to use this
same technique for getting
the Fourier series for f of x
equals the absolute value of x
on the interval
from minus pi to pi,
it turns out that capital F of
x would be pi over 2 minus 4
over pi summation over n odd
cosine nx over n squared.
By the way, if this
looks a little bit
like the previous
problem, notice that this
is more than just coincidence.
If you differentiate
the square root of x--
I'm sorry, if you differentiate
the absolute value
of x, what is the derivative?
It's minus 1 for x negative
and positive 1 for x positive.
It's the function that we were
just talking about before,
only it doesn't exist
at x equals 0, you see?
What I'm driving at over here
is that it's not surprising
that the terms in here are the
integrals of the terms that
were in our previous summation.
But notice that the absolute
value of x is an even function.
Consequently, it's the cosine
terms which appear here
rather than the sine terms.
And again, I've run the risk of
drawing my own diagrams here.
I have plotted this
for n equals 3,
meaning I've plotted y equals
pi over 2 minus 4 over pi times
the quantity cosine x
plus cosine 3x over 9.
And that's represented
by this curve
drawn in the accentuated
chalk over here.
And again, notice how even for
just a small number of terms,
we have already captured in the
large the shape of the curve y
equals the absolute value
of x, which by the way
contrasts very sharply
with power series.
Remember how power
series worked?
First of all, you had to require
that the function that you
were talking about possessed
derivatives of all orders.
Secondly, when you wanted to
fit the function by its power
series, you picked
a particular point.
Remember what you got?
You first got a tangent
line approximation.
Then you got a
quadratic approximation
that fit the curve in a
neighborhood at this point
better than the
straight line did.
But after a while, the
thing would sag off.
Then you added a cubic term.
And that fit even
better for a while.
And then again something
weird might happen.
And you kept on going like
this so that ultimately,
even though you had uniform
convergence, what you were
doing was you were getting
a splendid fit near one
particular point and slowly but
surely, and actually very, very
slowly, and also actually,
very surely, but you
may not have noticed it,
these approximations were
starting to fit better and
better as you went out here.
But the least square
approximations
would not be too good.
In other words,
out here someplace,
there was starting to become
some drastically large errors.
On the other hand, the Fourier
representation does what?
It fits the curve that you're
talking about very, very
nicely very, very quickly.
And this is one reason
why Fourier series
are as powerful as they are.
And by the way, again,
to end on a nice theme,
Fourier series probably
have as much space
devoted to them in
pure mathematics
as they do in
applied mathematics.
It's a beautiful topic
from both points of view.
But I felt that for
our lesson today,
since it is a finishing touch
to essentially the equivalent
of three-plus
semesters of calculus,
that we should juxtaposition
the old and the new
and show the peaceful
coexistence versus
this idea of polarization
where you either
have to be a traditionalist
or a modernist,
where you either have to be
an applied man or a purist,
that all of these ideas
mingle side by side.
And about the only choice
you have as a human
being depending on
what your interests are
is what proportion you're
going to mix them in.
Well, at any rate,
this brings us
to the part of the course
that always gives me
a little bit of remorse.
And that is, I hate to let
my captive audience go.
We have now been
through, as I say,
the equivalent of a couple of
years of mathematics together.
It has been a great
pleasure for me.
I hope it has been for you.
And once again, I would like to
thank everybody who has worked
with me on this,
but in particular,
the usual three people who
have been with me through thick
and thin on this, John
[? Fitchar, ?] project
self-study manager, who has
also done a lot of work with me
in helping me write
the study guide,
who has given me a lot of advice
on how to give these lectures
and how to prepare
them for the taping,
and has also been our
director for the taping,
to Miss Elise [? Pelletier, ?]
who in addition to her usual
secretarial work, has typed
much of our study guide and has
worked as a video technician
for us, and to our chief--
I'll just call him chief
of audio visual effects
at the center here,
Charles [? Patton. ?]
I am particularly indebted
to these three people,
indebted to a lot
of other people.
I thank you all for
being with me this long.
And I hope that our
paths will cross again.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.